my issue with Christianity is that it
takes the opposite view it takes an
arrogant one where God owes you love
where God owes you Mercy where God has
to come on this Earth humble himself and
be punished for your sins and I think
that's an arrogant View and I think the
arrogance is also tied into the doctrine
of God taking the form of a human where
humans are so arrogant that they refuse
to accept the ma majesty and power of
God that they seek to bring him down to
their level and that to me is not the
kind of relationship I want to have with
the one I owe everything too the one
that's created me the one that's blessed
me and the one that's given me
everything I have and that's that's my
point of discussion thank you Avery are
we done listening to this
driil because
here how how about this how about we
actually put this in actual perspective
The Arrogant position is one that
assumes that you in your sinfulness in
your measly State can live up to and
earn the love and forgiveness of a
sinless and eternally matchless God you
see the reality of the situation is that
Christians believe that God does not owe
us a single thing and fact he the only
thing he owes us is wrath and fury but
instead of giving us what we deserve he
does the impossible to bring us to him
not because he owes us but because he
chooses to love us that's that's that's
the difference between Islam and
Christianity go go ahead before I just I
lose my cool here I want to just just
share a verse this is 1 John 4 verse 18-
20 it says there is no fear in love but
perfect love casts out fear for fear has
to do with punishment and whoever fears
has not been perfected in love and
here's the part why I want you to see we
love because he first loved us so while
we were still Sinners while we were in
fear and in Rebellion God loved us
anyway and in response to that we love
him back it's us that owes him
everything not the other way around
according to Christianity you mind if I
also add something here Avery once
you're done yeah in Islam the Quran says
that Allah loves those who love him so
correct 100% correct yes so you you have
to love God first for him to then love
you so it's like the vice versa you love
first then okay now I owe you love here
it's the other way around God loved
first and so we owe him our love back
that's the difference yeah but that's
that's my point is that that in
itself is one is having to come to the
other first and humble themselves to the
other who should be coming to the other
first should it be the slave or the
master should it be the one who has done
everything for you before you even came
out of your mother's womb or should it
be the one who's had everything done for
them and that's where my perspective of
of it being an arrogant point of view
being a nonh humbling point of view how
can you come to him if he doesn't draw
you to
him he who said he doesn't draw me to
him but that's the point you notice so
you notice notice how according to that
you're saying who well who says he
doesn't do it so you're saying he does
that so notice who's the first one
reaching out even in your worldview God
God is the one who's doing is the first
one
doing the action correct and then you
respond well correct yes so this is in
Christianity God reaches out and we
respond with acceptance and and
gratitude saying yes we also have the
choice to say no so even you have VI is
that is that wrong well here's here's
where to me it is it is wrong right and
it's and it comes from one question that
I have yet to have a Christian answer
does God love everyone he's created yes
perfect
okay not in Islam so no no no no the the
question I reference no one's answered
is this next one which is if he loves
everyone how can he throw someone into
hell if he loves them that's kind of the
very question that you would have to say
because even in Islam every every every
person even Muslim
will eventually have to go to hell first
but nevertheless every Muslim to go to H
and there there Muslim there's no muslim
that will go directly to heaven where do
you see tell me where that's uh stated
in our chapter chapter 19 verse 70 and
71 or 71 and 72 it says there sing I'll
pull it up I'll pull it up for you it
says there's not a single one of you
that will not go down into it to hell no
read the verse read the verse exactly
I'm going to It Go calm
down zus Theus there is none of you who
will not pass over it that is the
Hellfire this is a decree correct that
is true must
fulfill that is true but don't don't
don't don't lie about the meaning of the
verse pass over it on the so there is
this walkway pass stop he just read it
he just read it in the Arabic it says go
into it I got it right here it's go
into yeah even the sahaba people like
Umar was afraid when he was going to die
because he was like he doesn't know if
Allah is going to bring him out of the
Hellfire because of
1971-72 so he was Umar was crying about
this let me no you're
misrepresenting and I'll explain each
verse so what what is the verse you say
he will go into the fire because I'm a
first uh my first language is Arabic so
I can go ahead and and and tell you what
it actually says literally go ahead
what's the verse watch this so verse 7
what the number
1971 but let me read to you the verse
let me read it to you this is starting
at verse
68 my brother I'm reading please Bree
bro it's okay now by the L by your lord
we shall surely muster them and the
satans then we shall parade them about
gehenna hell hobbling on their knees
then we shall pluck forth from every
party whichever of them was the most
hardened in disdain of the all merciful
then we shall then we shall know very
well those most deserving to burn there
not one of you there is not not one of
you there is but he shall go down to it
no means that's what that's exactly what
it says what it means it does that's not
what it means okay watch this that for
your lord is a thing decreed determined
verse 72 then we shall deliver those
that were God-fearing deliver them from
where from the which is above it we all
have to walk across the okay we all have
to walk across the S because our Prophet
peace be upon him already interpreted
this verse for us and he's put our
hearts at ease okay he has already
interpreted that every Muslim will have
to walk across the the is a no that's
not the same thing here that's not the
same thing here that's not what it's
talking about right here it says you're
going down into the fire into
gehenna I have Muslim for
wait a second wait a second you still
you still haven't answered my question
you came back calm
down you're not dealing with it you have
here where it says you haven't dealt
with my question then we shall deliver
those that are God-fearing and the
evildoers we shall leave there so wait
are the evildoers going to be left on
the bridge well let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question okay
let me ask you a question come on man I
asked you a straightforward question
question bro and I asked you one black
doct 21 you didn't answer it I said if
God loves all of us why would he throw
some of us evil doers gonna be left on
the bridge no the evildoers will burn in
hell fire so guess unforunately says for
that it says so look it says there's not
one of you that but shall go down to it
this is a decree determined by your lord
then we shall deliver those that were
God-fearing and the evildoers we shall
leave there so both the evildoers and
the God-fearing are in the same place
but then the God-fearing eventually get
delivered from that place where the
evildoers are so that's the even even
even if your interpretation is correct
so let's take a step back and say your
interpretation of what you're reading is
correct which it's not but even if your
interpretation is correct what is that
same verse end with it
says and we shall save from it those who
were righteous and God conscious right
you're
that's you could not you could yeah but
they're not being punished in hell they
won't feel the fire of hell they won't
feel the torment of hell they're
not like Abraham did not feel the
torment of hell and I have hold on hold
on have you heard the that says give me
the verse stop give me the verse that
says when they go down to hell they're
not going to feel it give me the verse
give me the verse where it says when
they go down to hell they're not going
to f i don't believe I don't believe it
says they will go down to Hell I have
never heard this in my life you just
gave an interpret I'm telling you what
you can't interpret My Religion for me
and you don't have any
scholar but see you guys you
guys even you're doing too much man
black like we just read we just read
right comment section comment section
what do we do here all all we do is read
right we
don't we don't add we don't take away we
just read read and you know what's funny
he said you don't interpret my religion
and what is what have we been doing you
answer my question or not hold on hold
on K well you keep asking me to hold on
but you're not letting me speak well
well when well when you interrupt me
when I'm speaking this is the first time
I've asked you like when on talking so
please show some respect show some Decor
he said don't interpret My Religion
Don't interpret My Religion but what
have we been hearing since the since the
time this man has stepped up here he's
been interpreting our religion and
placing it in a way that we would never
even see our religion in he's been
interpreting our religion but all we do
is simply read his text and supposedly
we're doing something that we can't do
does that seem fair Avery nah so so why
is it it's not okay for us to do it when
we just read but you haven't stated
anything in our religion haven't quoted
any of our texts and yet expect us to
believe that you have the proper
perspective in our religion does that
make
sense so if Allah loves the Muslims why
is he sending those he loves to hell can
I speak now uninterrupted or no if as
long as you answer directly I have told
you I do not believe that he does I have
told you that directly I do not believe
that that is what the verse means okay I
have I have never heard this
interpretation ever I've never heard
this interpretation I have always heard
and I've asked about this verse to
Scholars before and they pulled the
Hadith where the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon Him interprets this that every
human being will have to walk across
theat my question is
why are you deflecting from answering
the question I've posed to you this is
not to prove this this this live is not
to prove that Islam is incorrect this
live is for you is for me to prove Jesus
is not God so I've asked you a direct
question that you've cowered away from
which
isone why does he Enter Hell anybody
chrisan will ever answer this this
question no Christian willever
we we already have but but here Avery
notice what he said he said his job is
to come up here and prove that Jesus is
not God let me ask you this question
logic has he even touched that topic
since he's been up here no he hasn't no
so even by his own admission hold on
hold on so even by his own admission he
hasn't been doing what he's gotten up
here to do yeah no not not only that
here's here's notice and you won't
answer the question it's so ridiculously
cowardice notice your answer the
question answer the question you're the
you're shut your stupid mouth and just
listen dude because you're just
embarrassing yourself being loud and
just wrong you yourself brought in
objection you're trying to say that
Christianity is false because if God
loves all his creatures and sends some
of them to Hell who he loves then
therefore Christianity is false okay
going with your logic we're showing you
how your objection backfires do not come
and try to put standards and a criteria
on us in and that backfires against you
that is a failed argument 101 bad
argumentation 101 don't bring me glass
houses shouldn't throw stones don't
bring me an argu
against Christianity that works against
you something that
we this is this shows Christianity as fa
but for you since it does reject Islam
now since your God sends people who he
loves to hell and you said that that
means Christianity is false so then be
consistent and say Islam is false now
because of that if you want to object to
that then I need you to answer the verse
when it says here they will deliver we
will deliver those that were God-fearing
from where and the evildoers we shall
leave there where where are the
evildoers being left where the
God-fearing people are being brought out
of where's what's that place bro there
are hadiths that clearly state that
Hellfire is forbidden on groups of
people and it speaks to to who those
groups of people are also IB Abbas do
you know who Abbas is me theith I will
let me finish my point and then I'll
give you the no I I I do mine you
brought up you said that this is in a
Hadith show me in the Hadith that
contradicts this and by the way try to
keep people top here if a Hadith
contradicts what the Quran says then
beautiful I guess we does not contradict
it it interprets
it this is you can't you can't tell me
that it contradicts the verse when you
don't even know the meaning of the word
in Arabic and you don't know the
interpretation of the verse show me show
me okay the Hell Fire is forbidden to
touch a man or woman who is always
accessible polite and tender in
nature where's what's the name and
number give me the are you kidding me
what's the name and number the name okay
I'm pulling up the name and number so I
can read it myself show everybody okay
here it is it's because I'm I'm not be
honest with you I'm not aith scholar so
but here's the
number no there's no excuse it's an it's
it's why I don't know the number and
have it memorized so I have to look it
up
okay 641 what is that again say it's
slower for
me 641 RI 641 let's see here
641 was it Y and ABB said that this
verse means that they will cross it on
theat I pulled that up as well and I'm
happy to send you that Hadith yeah I'm
gonna trust
ab's interpretation of
thatth over your inter
show me show me where the verse says
there because I have right here where
Umar says that because of this verse
he's crying and he's in fear of how that
he will be brought out of the Hellfire
because of this verse so he understands
it to me yeah because he's a humble man
and he doesn't because he's able man and
he doesn't he won't he won't make any
claim he won't make any claims that he's
guaranteed salvation because only God
you're missing it khed he understood the
verse to mean he's going to go to
Hellfire even as a Believer and doubts
that Allah will bring him out so here's
the verse reported messenger of Allah
said shall I not tell you whom the
Hellfire is forbidden to touch it is
forbidden to touch a man who is always
accessible having polite and tender
nature so if this is the Hadith that
he's that he's going to then he's
showing us that the Hadith literally
contradicts the Quran when the Quran
says that all of you are going to go
down to the Hellfire so you just showed
us that the Hadith contradicts the Quran
that's good show us another one oh
where'd he go I didn't drop him